so i want to begin today by discussing
two stories that may at first seem
basically unrelated first we go to
politico where earlier in the week over
100 staffers signed a letter
and sent it to their ceo further
expressing their outrage and grief over
the fact that ben shapiro wrote a
newsletter for them
that one time weeks ago yes you remember
that from weeks ago they're still
talking about it
even though two or three weeks have
passed since the offensive newsletter
which
was not offensive or provocative at all
still
these staffers have not overcome the
trauma that it caused them they demanded
an apology from their boss
along with treatment for their ptsd
which they say must include a dozen
therapeutic bunny rabbits in the office
which they can pick up and cuddle
anytime they feel scared
that last part is a joke but only barely
in the irony of all ironies
the letter also insists upon i'm not
kidding
greater workplace diversity yes they are
shouting for more diversity
while in the very same breath shouting
for less diversity
they are upset that somebody with
different views was allowed to write a
newsletter
and the reason they're upset they say is
that they want more
diversity but of course we understand
what they mean by diverse
diversity for them the perfect image of
diversity
what diversity is perfect image is a
room full of dozens of people of
different races ethnicities genders and
sexual proclivities
all saying the exact same thing in
unison
it's the kind of diversity that will be
best achieved once we're all replaced by
robots
which frankly at this point can't happen
soon enough so that's one story
let's look at another like i said these
are related and i'll explain why
the daily wire has a report about a
university of illinois chicago law
professor jason kilbourne
the professor has been indefinitely
suspended after a campus controversy
that stems originally
from a question on an exam now in the
exam
kilbourn presented to the students a
hypothetical case
dealing with race and gender
discrimination
okay now i imagine this is the kind of
thing that students in law
law school encounter a lot hypothetical
situations and cases that they have to
analyze
right so in this hypothetical case in an
employee quit her job
after um and now i'm going to read
directly from the exam text this is what
it says
after she attended a meeting in which
other managers expressed their anger
at plaintiff calling her an n
blank and b blank
that's what it says on the exam n and b
it does not say the word themselves it
just says n and b
with a little blank space next to each
letter this was enough to provoke
outrage the black law students
association spoke out claiming that
students were shocked and
distracted by the slur on the exam they
couldn't even take the test because they
were so they were so upset
even though again the slur was not
written out one student said she had
heart palpitations
just from seeing the letter n on the
page
let's hope she never watches sesame
street when they get to you know today
today the letter is in
um a petition was was was circulated it
gained 400 signatures
demanding among other things that
killborn be forced to take cultural
sensitivity training
for writing the letter n on an exam
now you might ask how the hell can a law
professor even teach his students about
racial discrimination cases
if he can't so much as refer to a racial
if you can't even refer to a racial slur
then how can you communicate what to do
legally in these situations what if what
if he was what if this was a an oral uh
uh lecture and he had just said the n
word not the actual word but he had said
quote
the n-word would that have been shocking
and traumatizing too i suppose so
meanwhile of course most of these
students listen to music every day
where the full word is said shouted
really over and over again that causes
them no emotional pain
but but someone with the wrong skin
pigmentation even so much as
refers to the word however indirectly
it'll cause them to collapse into tears
barely able to breathe
sure it's all completely absurd and it
only gets more absurd
here's what happened next kilborn in the
midst of the great outrage over the
letter n
had a zoom meeting with a member of the
black law students association during of
course that conversation killborn was
asked
why the dean of the school had not given
kilborn the petition
from the blsa so that he could read it
himself
and to that killborn joked that he
hadn't been given the letter
quote because uh is a quote i suspect
she's afraid if i saw the horrible thing
said about me in the letter i would
become homicidal
obvious joke but the blsa member who
heard this
promptly reported that comment to the
school's behavioral threat assessment
team
at which point kilburn was placed on
indefinite leave for threatening the
students
now how does this relate back to the
political situation
because in the case of politico these
are alleged adults in the real world
behaving as though they are so
emotionally fragile
that they might dissolve into a puddle
if you so much as
give them a funny look in the case of a
law professor controversy these are
college kids with the same level of
emotional fragility
this yet again demonstrates an important
point that i've made before and i'll
make again
we assumed and declared for years
that the so-called snowflakes on college
campuses would would leave the pampered
confines of academia
go out into the real world experience a
rude awakening
and then after some painful adjustment
become mature and well-adjusted adults
that's that's what you know that's what
we assumed uh
wait wait till they get out into the
real world oh they're gonna see how it
really works won't they
but that's not what happened instead
snowflakes have gone out into society
and remade it
in their own image as painful as it is
for us to acknowledge
they have not gotten the rude awakening
that we hoped and that they so much
deserve
and there's no reason to think they ever
will at least not in the way
we thought they would this should have
been an easy thing to foresee
in hindsight a lot of things are easy to
foresee in hindsight
after all each generation inherits the
earth and makes society into what they
want it to be
if a bunch of emotionally stunted
overgrown babies take over
why would we think that they'd all
magically become mature adults
and besides this is not a process that
happened overnight and it didn't begin
with the millennial generation the
boomers collectively speaking
as a generation as much as they
complained about the millennials largely
have been
incompetent immature and selfish
themselves that's why they've ruined
every institution they've touched
and they're leaving the country in a
much worse state than it was when they
inherited it
the point simply is that many of the
rules
that make up the real world are
determined by society
now physical rules the laws of physics
and so forth are independent of our
whims and attitudes obviously as much as
we
these days like to pretend otherwise but
a rule like
society rewards maturity and
self-sufficiency
that kind of rule is certainly not
universal or innate
you have to build and maintain a society
that operates by that rule
if you don't then it won't unfortunately
in in our case we increasingly live in a
society that rewards and caters to
the loudest whiniest most selfish and
immature people
it's not just college campuses anymore
that work that way
one other point about this as i'm
thinking about it you know we've
probably also made a mistake
in using phrases like snowflakes as i
have here to describe the college kids
crying over a letter they read on an
exam or
staffers at uh politico writing a letter
to complain about a ben shapiro article
we call them snowflakes
well this implies that they're merely
sensitive right they're
they're too they're too sensitive and
we've said that many times
but the truth is actually almost the
opposite of that
because the sensitivity is performative
what drives this is not sensitivity but
rather hatred
resentment a desire for power
was the black law students association
actually traumatized by the letter
n on a piece of paper do we really do we
believe that they
actually the student who said she had
heart palpation does anyone really
believe
that she's sincere when she said that or
did they see it as an opportunity to
vindictively assert their dominance over
and destroy a man they despise and
despis despise in this case largely for
the color of his skin
and what they believe that color
represents i would say the latter
the snowflake act is just that it's an
act it's a tool
used by these so-called snowflakes to
get what they want it's a power play
and an extremely effective one it turns
out
so where do we go from here what do we
do with all this
what does it mean well all it means is
that our problem
is how society is fundamentally
constructed no big deal that's it we
we just have to reconstruct society from
the ground up that's the uh we can't
wait for the real world to solve the
problems
the real world has been reshaped by
these very same people
so we have to reconstruct it from the
ground up that's all it should only take
several generations to
that's the good news and also the bad
news
but there's no time like the present to
get started
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content